diamo ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fallite
allora nell'ultimo episodio riuscite a
questo bordello sono io con l'olio al
contagio è veramente un'impresa andare
avanti abbassare il volume e cielo anche
fatta e non ce l'ho fatta
allora stavo dicendo dell'ultimo
episodio ragazzi son riuscito a fare
quattro livelli che per questo tipo di e
primis non è niente mar quattro livelli
non in un video normale 10 subito sono
pochissimi
in questo è per questo sono tantissimi
perché questi livelli sono difficili
come la morte c'è super meat boy il
confronto è un gioco c è tutto a posto
ragazzi per adesso tutto che sono
riuscito a fare con degli alibi di prova
anche questa volta riuscire a farne 4
non ne sono veramente convinto
esattamente e torniamo all'inizio a ok
mi hai portato qua va bene allora ancora
fattibile ha però fatto io devo corri
corri corri che ti spara mash up
perfetto
proprio lui ho preso la freccia in
faccia per sempre il traguardo non è
vero quanto manca al traguardo che sono
qua per miracolo imi che c'è un
traguardo ti prego dimmi che esiste
dimmi che esiste attenzione proprio lui
il primo livello sono riuscito
quanti ne mancano ragazzi di curiosità
level a lot
in che senso ha sbloccato le livelli
speciali fighissimo livello speciale non
l'ho mai fatto
ok poi proviamo a farlo abbiamo scelto
fanno altri due con enti e poi livello
speciale ragazzi allora let's golf
meraviglioso la partenza è buona e ragga
faccia a faccia parte dell'ospedale
c'è veramente strano che partenza era
bordo ascensori non ragazzi sono curiosi
di vedere la roba speciale che ho
sbloccato si sblocca uno ogni mille anni
praticamente torre buono ho sbloccato la
bomba me la prenderò in culo vela
prendono il culo non me la sono allora
se vado piano teoricamente ce la faccio
qua salta prima si è un casino
no statale primo è servito e ma non
posso farcela e meno un posto se il gela
bomba cosa faccio non possono andare
indietro andare avanti muoio o una
freccia dentro la faccia ma fa niente
ragazzi della norma prevede strisca
togliermelo non sono riuscito a
togliermi la pagina teniamola tanto pare
dalla fashion si è sbloccata la bomba
non era anche prima l'avevo saltata ma
scusami che piano e torna indietro
mamma mia che giocava ragazzi tutto a
posto c'è un pisello allora calmi ancora
vivo sono ancora vivo
meno male meno male che ho vinto perchè
non non so quanto potevo continuare così
verranno in una posizione era un po
scomodo secondo me allora i due livelli
la mia fatti se riesco a fare anche
quello poi vado subito sullo speciale
raga sono meglio orgoglioso di come sta
andando suo attivismo by perchè è molto
difficile ve lo assicuro perfetto io
devo stare zitto allora ragazzi in due
ore per tornare quando ce l'abbiamo
fatta
se riesco a correre saltare e
meraviglioso
non so dove sono molto prima e quello il
fatto capito credo di essere molto quota
che una volta stato abbastanza perfetto
o una freccia nel cervello non fa nulla
sono intelligente adesso sono vivo sono
io a posto a posto a posto apposta posta
pastore
proprio lui proprio lui vale ragazzi lo
hanno fatto i tre me ne mancano 4 e
finisco etiche sarebbe fantastico ma non
lo faccio oggi perché voglio
assolutamente fare il livello dove mi fa
scegliere personaggio livello speciale
ce ne sono 4 sbloccato il primo non
direi che la partenza è buona non so che
livello sia però sono speciali e voglio
provare a farne uno almeno la mia volta
non so niente credo sia difficilissimo
aggiunta a giudicare dal fatto che sono
livelli e solo dopo un tot di nei fatti
che ci sarà sicuramente un casino
però noi ci proviamo per adesso va tutto
bene che mi sembra incredibile
cos'è sta roba ok ho capito
bello bello non è vero aso solo è un
misto di cose che ho fatto negli altri
livelli l'ho finito
[Musica]
faccia distrutta alla fine efficace
molto bene sono soddisfatto del video di
oggi veramente per almeno lotito quattro
livelli
proviamo a questo punto ad andare un po
avanti con con eddy perché almeno nei
prossimi livelli delle ccie faccio
ancora un livello perché almeno nel
prossimo video prova a finirlo visto che
mancano poi sono di tre livelli
teoricamente cela dovrei fare nel
prossimo video se riesco almeno fare
questo e quasi si è quasi sicuro che nel
proseguito riuscirò a farlo prova ad
andare avanti ancora un po secondo me ce
l'ha se è una bella partita questa è la
prima volta che mi capita su itunes
novelli fare una bella partita di dire
mamma mia come sono soddisfatto della
mia vita di merda che è ok ho fatto una
parte che ho fatto l'ho fatto anche la
seconda
ok quando ci sono arrivato mamma mia
sono morto peccato sono mi avesse
colpito con un danno mortale a quest'ora
sarei ancora cioè erano esattamente nel
punto dove sarei dovuto rimanere ma
majal di volo dovuto però capito come
fare quindi sono tranquillo non ho
capito un cazzo perfetto e vabbè ma è
difficilissimo
a parte il fatto che sono ancora di no
non è vero
il problema è che non non riesco a
frenare in tempo e solo quello problema
perché vado troppo veloce in quel film
andrà poi lento solo che sono doppi
letto rischio a morte ok stava suonato
lentissimo e dove vado come faccio a non
mi piglia i pm ma allora ma allora cosa
non fare c'è allora ho trovato provo a
vedere se riesco a fare in un altro modo
come
come penso che sia vediamo se funziona
perché normalmente se quello è la
normalità non si può farcela almeno non
credo si possa fare
però se notate se notate quassù sti cosi
ci puoi andare sopra quindi se mi dà lo
slancio da questi no insomma non si
potrebbe peccato però perché da sovrasti
così poteva aiutarmi la propulsione o un
buco c'è la lega madonna va bene rega
l'ultima volta ci riprovo normalmente
perché ho provato anche la l'escamotage
però non puoi salire per un niente
peccato vabbè ma che sfiga o provate a
saltarla ancora una volta cipro ho
provato a saltare oltre perché ho detto
vabbè prova a vedere se ha sorpassato in
velocità ma non ha funzionato purtroppo
perché proprio dire manca proprio quella
roba non possa rallentare il tempo
quindi o lo trovo un escamotage non lo
so comunque dai proviamoci di nuovo ok
allora proviamoci ilaria normalmente
anche se la vedo dura ok non so come ho
fatto
non so come ho fatto non so come ho
fatto non riuscirò mai più non riuscirò
mai più
ma questa questa l'ho fatta ragioni da
genio
[Musica]
benissimo benissimo benissimo benissimo
ragazzi non riuscirò mai più a fare sta
parte quindi io vinco o stacco ok no no
no no no sì sì no no
[Musica]
peccato raga peccato peccato prove delle
siciliane sull'ultima elmaleh e stato un
caso sul milione e stato un caso sul
milione non ci riuscirò mai più ci provo
ma proprio per perché ci sono riuscito a
prima volta vi dico va bene ok
devo stoppare frutto io ho fatto un
disastro ok ho fatto questo c'è un mare
di acqua ho paura che vada in tutto il
corto circuito
ci vediamo al prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]